[Musique]
à partir de maintenant de 15h à 16h vous
avez moins 25% sur le ticket de caisse
total
profitez de jour
[Musique]
cette journée c'est une opération de
déstockage de vie d'entrepôt en tout cas
c'est l'occasion de faire profiter à
tous les gens de la commune de jeux à
des prix réduits et on fait un appel au
volontariat dans les équipes pour venir
travailler aujourd'hui on doit être
entre 20 et 25 nous sommes venus donner
un coup de main sur cette opération
[Musique]
boucher car c'est une association qui
s'occupe des personnes à la retraite et
des personnes âgées plus généralement
qui vient leur apporter des repas ou qui
leur apportent du réconfort ou tous les
jours
[Musique]
dans les actions RSE on en a plusieurs
la plus significative est celle
d'accessus c'est à dire c'est la
création de jeux ou le développement de
jeux qui permettent aux gens qui ont des
troubles cognitifs de pouvoir travailler
la mémoire travailler la vue travailler
le toucher l'appréhension et ainsi de
suite et puis ensuite un certain nombre
de stratégies RSE au niveau du
développement du produit au niveau de la
taille des afin de les réduire de
réduire l'empreinte carbone de réduire
le plastique
[Musique]
j'ai eu le papier à l'entrée comme quoi
c'était pour des bénéfices d'association
et j'en profite en même temps grâce à ça
c'est une excellente nouvelle non je ne
savais pas je suis un spécialement pour
l'aspect des stockage parce que j'aime
bien tout ce qui est tout ce qui recycle
et de seconde main donc l'idée me plaît
généralement et là je suis encore plus
motivé par le fait que ça ait reversé
par une association